good morning millennials welcome back to
the toast happy Wednesday it is hump day
a favorite here at the toast make sure
this is your reminder that you hump
someone you love today and there's
nobody I love more no girl who grinds my
gears gets me more
alive
then Jackie oh hey Jax hi thank you I
love every day to hear what you're gonna
say about me it must be like so much
pressure every day having to come up
with something new and flattering and it
never really goes the other way though I
compliment you throughout the show it's
not pressure it's not pressure it's just
this you know need for creativity I
don't want my interest to ever feel
stale oh I don't think anyone could ever
say that they are
well good that means I'm doing a good
job at your job at me job that is your
job oh no I'm gonna lose my job what's
that from it's a tick tock sound
everyone's like oh no I'm panicking
cause I'm gonna lose my job and then
when they found like the actual origin
of the video it's actually really dark
I'm sure you know those um no it's not
what you think
you know those people who like set up
and pretend to be like teenagers on the
internet and find predators and then
meet up with them and like film them
like are you talking to a 13 year old
yeah like they do it in an official
capacity usually sometimes it's just
like people's YouTube channels not fun
but like to scare Predators into
and so they caught this guy and he was
like this freaky looking dude and they
were following him around with the
camera when they met up in the parking
lot he's like no I'm panicking because
I'm gonna lose my job I think he was
Irish or something it was honestly like
[__] hysterical I hope he did lose
his job oh my God that's crazy I told
you dark origins of tick-tock sounds
that's crazy yeah I I love finding out
the origins of like viral trending audio
a lot of the time it comes from like old
reality TV that I know you know that's
like what everyone was doing you know
Gia judice's song oh of course I knew it
but like people were shook to find out
what it actually most people didn't know
but that's also from reality TV is hey
how y'all doing of course also
today trained me it's Marlo from Real
houses of Atlanta like sometimes I
recognize the bid sometimes I recognize
the voice but every now and then I get a
little surprised like I'm gonna lose my
job some of mine that are my favorite at
cut should come from podcasts which it's
like do you feel like you want to talk
less [__]
um
no cause uh I like it
yeah we did kind of go viral on Tick
Tock like that's why Tick Tock can't be
banned like what would we go viral on
reels shorts
Shorts YouTube shorts shirts maybe we'll
have to start posting our podcast Clips
to Facebook Stories
and I know it's probably an accident I
have never in my life seen anyone post a
Facebook story except your husband but I
think it's something with his Instagram
that automatically sends his Instagram
stories I don't think he knows or no
he's just like he doesn't story that
often so when he does he's like sure
let's blow it up what if I just what if
I just shared it to Facebook what if
they just syndicated to all my channel
right it's actually really cute when I
see it but that's the only time I ever
see like someone I know doing Facebook
Stories that's so funny I'll have to
tell him he was called out every now and
then when I post a Instagram story
they're like want to Syndicate this to
your Facebook I'm like are you trying to
ruin my career trying to ruin my life my
reputation same family I have an image
to uphold yeah can't be seen on Facebook
Stories no
um sorry tangential
yeah but that's what the show is
the tangent the tangent feel free to go
off on one anytime well it's Wednesday
just some housekeeping big day here you
know we got lots to talk about we also
have deer toasters our weekly advice
segment we have three really good
submissions I think I think we'll be
able to make a lot of impact a lot of
positive change
yeah we're gonna say something yeah I
was just gonna agree with you I was
going to Concur and it's also our last
real episode of the week because I'm
headed to Portugal tonight I have been
just
non-stop you know prep packing make sure
everything is settled at home getting
Ben oh my God Ben like still not packed
still not packed we're leaving for the
airport in four hours still not packed
what is he doing he's at a trade show um
which is important you know Vin expo's a
big one Javits Center so I'll allow it
but pack
pack yeah no I don't understand these
men
no it's it's next level and he got back
from Boston on Friday that bag was still
not unpacked and you need to use the
same bag oh my God I just it could never
be me and I'm really trying to learn
like as I get older just like not to get
so pressed about it's not me like I'm
packed like why can't I just be happy
with my productivity but it's because my
productivity is irrelevant when my
partner they're only as strong as your
weakest link thank you so I know some
some people be like don't be such a
[__] wife like let Hill get packed but
it's like it starts impacting me if he
was when he goes on his solo trips and
he throws a t-shirt into a backpack the
day before I don't [__] care but I'm
going and it's like it's a big trip it's
International we need our Global Entry
like there's a lot of productivity that
needs to be done before yeah and he just
doesn't understand just wait till you
have a baby and it's like I pack for me
and Harry and we're all packed before
Zach even gets his suitcase out no it's
like there's no excuse and it's like I'm
packing me and him so it's like I'm it's
not like I'm some low maintenance no
you're a queen a glamor puss especially
for traveling of course glamor glamor
better outfit every day of course right
oh and me and Harry like share our
luggage a lot of the time it's just
easier
um and Zack gets his own and still can't
get done he's like over packs and I'm
like I'm wearing a different outfit
every day and I'm sharing and I got
Harry's crap in here crap you know he
has a lot of crap a lot of crap you know
what I actually woke up this morning
thinking and I wanted to I do so I do
put some of Harry's crap inside like we
but we split Harry's stuff that's what
we do that way we only have to have two
suitcases life hack life hack
um I just thought you know as I was
walking into work this morning something
I wanted to share with you that I only
really wanted to share on the podcast so
people can know like how nice I am
um I really miss you like I really like
I woke up today some days are harder
than others honestly like and I woke up
today maybe it's because like I I've had
like a 12 hour migraine so I'm not
feeling my best I'm feeling low I have
like a busy like kind of your big sis
anxiety riddle riddle day in front of me
and I just was singing like I miss my
family it's tastes like today like it's
not cool that I can't like wrap the
toast and go over to Olivia's house and
see the kids and just like
hang it's not cool it's not cool no I
know I miss you I miss you too and I
actually had a dream about New York last
night and I was just like having an
amazing time three bucks two two bags
yeah because we don't bring one for
Harry right one one roll
um and I keep being like you know maybe
I'll just like what if I just come to
New York next week I can't come next
week because I have a doctor's
appointment I have a friend's birthday
and it's just like I busy Florida things
and then like the following week like
then you're coming so soon so yeah it
doesn't make sense and then you're gonna
be here for
at like over a week which is nice so
we'll we'll look for we'll shoot for
April yeah Jax and I are spending
Passover together which is just lovely
and also I'm coming down a few days
early because Jax and I have kind of
been like not even talking about how
we've been asked to speak at a
prestigious University yeah we are they
want our expertise academic girlies and
we're gonna go talk to some students and
we're gonna I think impact you know
positively on the new generation I hope
yeah I don't see how we couldn't I don't
see it we couldn't we're so that's
exciting that's exciting our first like
academic I have to figure out what I'm
gonna wear I need a pair of glasses yeah
I have to figure out what I'm gonna wear
like I need something that fits well
yeah always uh need something that fits
you need something that makes me look
snatch to the gods
need something that makes me look
literary yeah like a merit scholar yeah
maybe I should do some shopping today
even though I just got some like
stretchy dresses from skims
that should be good for just like
maternity wear yeah but I think that's a
little skimpy for yeah University no we
can't be looking like big [__] at the
University yeah cannot and we're always
looking like horse so it'll be hard for
us to find something
um dressing like a [__]
and stop stopping the negative self-talk
another viral audio of ours that went
viral on Tick Tock I'm surprised like
more of our audience don't go viral
because really any moment could like
this one right here
yeah
right
do it oh my God Jackie's so cute like
isn't she so cute today like do you have
bad moves to deliver that you're just
buttering me up no no maybe it's like
because I'm leaving the country I feel
like I'm gonna miss my family no more
you're feeling I'm just sick I'm just
missing the family and I had to run over
for dinner on Monday night and obviously
you and Olivia weren't there so it just
[__] sucked like yeah
just really missing you missing you too
turdy's missing her Lou will be reunited
soon
I know we'll be together again cause
everywhere I go every smile I see I know
you are there Marshall Anthony whenever
Brian sings that song he puts by the way
that's something Brian and I haven't
comment he'll put his dog's name into
popular music whenever he can and he
calls his dog Marshall Anthony even
though Anthony is not his last name
um and now I can't sing that song with
Marshall Anthony that's so funny I was
gonna say are you excited to travel with
the snatcher this weekend I am I love
getting some down time with the satch
um we've been like talking a lot you
know sharing like outfits I just feel
like I'm hanging out with a popular
crowd you know yeah I was FaceTiming her
last night she was like showing me some
dresses yeah that she was thinking about
it's very exciting to kind of like roll
with the popular Crow you know yeah I'm
excited for you you're like my nerdy
friend who I like leave behind to go
hang out with the popular kids totally
LOL but you can really only be yourself
around me yeah and you know the real me
yeah but at a certain point like my
feelings do get hurt when it's like of
course you're when you're with the
populars it's like I don't exist yeah no
and like we have this Arrangement like
when I'm with the populars like we
pretend like we don't know each other
yeah and that eventually starts to chip
away at you at yourself it does at first
I was like listen you know
she's a social animal she has to do what
she has to do
Rising Tides rise all shines like she'll
you know get cool and then make me cool
that's how it starts yeah yeah but I'm
also like the nerd with like too much
pride I don't want to be a part of the
popular crew you are the nerd with too
much pride
I'm the nerd who takes off his glasses
and everybody realizes he's handsome
that's true you are handsome don't be
rude
don't be picking it
you're beautiful turdy thank you
um so we've got a great there's so much
to do today like these episodes we can't
outrun our memory cards
that's good that's really good I am so
impatiently waiting for Luke combs's new
album like every song that drops I
haven't even spoken about how deeply
connected and moved I am by his most
recent single joke you did talk about it
oh oh sorry okay but what's crazy is I I
love the song it's just like I love
every Luke song but it doesn't speak to
me as much as the other one he released
before it love you anyway oh my God one
of the most beautiful Luke songs of all
time I know but there's like a verse in
Joe that like really makes me tear up I
feel like if you've even been remotely
or like distantly known of someone who
struggles with addiction the song has to
make you cry listen to this part ready
some battles are fought on foreign
Shores
and some are far behind closed doors
wait hold on there's a better party
after that
damn no I know it's like so deep he's
such a poet and nobody even knows it
because he's just like you know this big
fisherman country man like no but they
know it
okay ready they know
some battles are fought on foreign
Shores
and some are fought behind closed doors
some Fall From Grace some lose their
wings
some find the peace salvation brings
it's so nice like I feel like if you're
like a sober queen or any sort of
addiction like I feel like that song
could be like a real
piece like a Solace for you you know um
speaking of songs about sobriety Charles
from Lady a recently got sober yes I
know and he put out a solo song
um oh wow about
I I think it's called as far as you
could like that pretty much like he like
he drank for as long as he could it took
him as far as he could right
um but he had to eventually put it down
it's beautiful it's like straight up
about his addiction to alcohol and how
it brought him like it you know gave him
the courage to me like to go up to his
wife he made her laugh also made her cry
oh no that's sweet I uh I'm really happy
for Charles from lady I feel like his
battle had been like this Open Secret in
country music like a lot of people knew
about it and like you really can't force
someone to make the change like they
have to want to do with themselves and I
recently saw him post his trip to rehab
and he looked very good he looked very
healthy like this light back in his face
so I'm excited for that journey and I'm
gonna listen to that song on the plane
today I can't wait to cry it's beautiful
added to your list I'll add it to my
list
um I've also been listening to Morgan
wallen's new album oh yes that's what I
wanted to ask you I just started it's so
long so I'm making songs in so good
what's so crazy is like I wasn't even
desperate for a new album yet like one
he puts out three new songs every few
weeks yeah and like the old album I'm
still obsessed with like it's not stale
to me so my cup run is over yeah my
thoughts initial thoughts on the album
and maybe I'm not able to see it yet
because it's just 36 songs but they all
they do sound like really repetitive
um like only a few of them really stand
out to me and maybe I need to listen to
it better to really get it but I was
just I don't think it compares to his
previous album but I do really love the
song Keith Whitley like love yeah I'm in
the middle of it but you know what album
I did complete a few times that was
wonderful King Webb's album um
Pink's album's good too but Mimi Webb
it's called Amelia and she's a star
we've got a lot of new music coming
Jonas Brothers Ed Sheeran Luke I
seriously like I cannot wait for Luke's
song yeah uh album I know but I still I
didn't I still put on Growing Up hours
every time I get in the car no of course
like I'm not tired of it I'm not tired
of it either but the singles he's been
dropping has been leaving me with this
thirst yeah I'm thirsty
I don't have enough time in the day to
listen to all this music I know but now
that I'm a driver maybe I will maybe
maybe not but let's get into everything
so much to discuss today plus gear
toasters we don't want to um
memory cards so without further Ado
taking up the memory cards here are the
fast side stories that you need to know
and today's episode is brought to you by
Noom Trends and fads come and go
especially when it comes to health and
wellness but Noom is not a fad they use
psychology not Trends to help you make
an intentional and sustainable choices
that are aligned with your values and
your weight loss goals so whatever your
reason for wanting to lose weight is
whether it's to feel better overall to
fit into certain clothing maybe you're
just at a place in your life where you
felt like it spirals a little bit and
you want to get back in control check
out Noom with their psychology-based
approach Newman Powers you to build more
sustainable habits and behaviors the
program helps you understand the science
behind your eating choices and why you
have cravings everyone's journey is
different so your daily lessons are
personalized to you and your goals so
whatever your health goals are the
flexible program focuses on progress
instead of perfection you can choose
your level of support from five minute
daily check-ins to personal coaching
progress is rarely a straight line and
off days are totally okay noon will help
you get back on track that's what I
really like about Noom it's like some
days you just can't and you don't have
to throw away all the progress that
you've made with noon like they account
for that you had a bad day you're
hungover or you're just feeling sad
that's okay we're gonna get you back on
track you don't have to start over just
because you messed up
stop chasing Health Trends and build
sustainable healthy habits with new
psychology-based approach sign up for
your trial today at noom.com toast
that's n o o m.com slash toast to sign
up for your trial today you can also
check out noom's first ever book it's
called the new mindset and it's a deep
dive into the into the psychology of
behavior change it's available to buy
now wherever books are sold again that
promo we have is noom.com toast
n-o-o-m.com toast today's episode is
also brought to you by the perfect bar
looking for a protein bar that actually
tastes good well look no further than
perfect bar with their lineup of fresh
from the fridge protein bars perfect bar
is exactly what you've been looking for
no chalky artificial aftertaste here
they're made with freshly ground nut
butter or organic honey in over 20
organic superfoods perfect bar has a
variety of products like protein bars
little snack size bars that are also
good and good for you you'll be sure to
find something you love I've been raving
about my favorite flavor which is the
dark chocolate chip peanut butter with a
little flaky salt I love um These Bars
won because I'm not like a big bar
person but because all of their
ingredients are like organic and it's
real food you keep them in the fridge
and there's just something about that
that feels like much better not like
eating some preservatives that's been
sitting on a shelf for a year
um they have a cookie dough texture
that's creamy and full of flavor and
they're unlike any other bars out there
and the snack size bars are the perfect
size they're packed with six grams of
protein and 150 calories so a little
goes a long way you will feel full
throughout the day you'll have energy
throughout the day you don't have that
crash they're made with whole food
ingredients they contain no artificial
preservatives and if you aren't already
convinced they're also non-GMO project
verified gluten-free soy-free kosher and
low GI perfect bar knows that it'll be
Love At First Bite so for a limited time
they're offering you a chance to try
their refrigerated protein bars for free
here's how it works sign up for email or
text upload a picture of your receipt
from your local grocery store and
they'll reimburse you the cost of one
bar it'll go directly into your venmo or
PayPal account all you have to do is go
to perfect snacks.com toast to get that
free perfect bar today that's perfect
snacks.com toast to get a free free
perfect bar today
that's just kind of what we do here at
the toast free food like I'm always
going to point you in the direction of
free food that's a little fun fact about
me
okay thank you Claudia our first story
and update
on the Scandal we've got a couple first
Raquel has broken her silence and put
out a statement exclusive to
Entertainment Tonight about
her apology I sing yeah quote I want to
apologize for my actions and my choices
foremost to Ariana and to my friends and
the fans so invested in our
relationships there is no excuse I am
not a victim and I must own my actions
and I deeply regret hurting Ariana
I'm reflecting on my choices speaking to
a counselor and I'm learning things
about myself such as my patterns of
codependency and addiction to being and
feeling loved I've sought emotional
validation through intimate connections
that are not healthy without regard for
my own well-being sometimes negatively
affecting others and often prioritizing
the intimate connection over my
friendships I'm taking steps to
understand my behavior and make
healthier choices although I chose to be
on a reality show accepting the good and
the bad that comes with it beyond my own
actions I've been physically assaulted
lost friendships received death threats
and hate mails in addition to having my
privacy violated
I've begun counseling to end my
unhealthy behavioral cycle learn to set
stronger emotional boundaries and learn
to protect my mental health I don't
expect sympathy understanding or
forgiveness right now I must focus on my
own health and well-being as I strive to
be a better person moving forward I will
prioritize my mental health and learn
from my mistakes
so this news broke on Friday
um so she learned all of that from a
counselor since Friday is a counselor
living with her
like I'm like you meet with the
counselor once a week okay maybe twice a
week or maybe it's something that like
she you know
knew about herself sort of over the
years and could see this pattern in
herself but like really couldn't
identify it until she blew up her whole
world with her actions I mean at the end
of the day there's quite literally
nothing she could say that would make
this better so like we're just we're
gonna pick apart whatever she says
um
like cool there's no we said that
yesterday there's absolutely nothing she
could say but she has to say something
yeah as far as what she could say I
think this is as good as it gets like
she's accepting responsibility she's not
a victim she's it's more than Tom
Sandoval did in his first statement
she's apologizing in the direction where
the apology needs to go that's all she
can do at this point there's nothing
that's gonna like
change hearts and Minds the chips have
are continuing to fall where they may
the out
what's the word the um
outcome no The Fallout yeah just it will
have to continue to fall out until
things can like even begin to conceive
of rebuilding forgiveness making it
better
um
in the final paragraph where she
references being physically assaulted
that she confirms a rumor that Sheena
had found out the night before it came
out and slapped her they were like I
think it was right after watch weapons
live right yeah when Sheena found out
apparently she either slapped her or
punched her in the face and Markel has
filed a restraining order again Sheena
so what and she was granted that the
restraining order a lot of people say
that it's like a ploy for her not to
have to show up to the reunion in two
weeks because she can't be within a
thousand feet of of Sheena but you know
what
zoom sheena's on Zoom no but I wonder
how restraining orders work with like
contact digital contact no so Sheen is
not at the reunion because bye even
though what Raquel did was really
terrible like you'll punch someone in
the face sheena's 100 wrong for that
it's like that's just so Sheena like so
erratic you know yeah just having such
like an extreme opposite reaction yeah
like instead of just having like a
level-headed reaction the entire time
and not setting up your friend with the
other friend and and then right
right he's so extreme both ways you're
so extreme both ways so that was like
and now she's gonna ruin if she
like I hope this doesn't stop Raquel
from coming to the reunion
and if Raquel doesn't go to the reading
like she obviously shouldn't be on the
show anymore that's been the rules
forever but the restraining order does
throw a wrench into things but for me it
means that Sheena won't be there yeah
you played yourself that was really dumb
of her and she's wrong you don't [__]
hit someone but and apparently like
Raquel has a black eye is what I heard
yeah I know it was like it was like a
[__] it was a punch and it must have
been something that left a mark because
she probably has pictures which granted
out of restraining order but I am
curious though about the timeline like
do you think she so Sheena found out
after watch Robin's live what's
Wednesday night the news broke on Friday
and apparently Ariana found out on
Thursday night
is it just a happenstance that Sheena
and Ariana found out two days apart or
did Sheena tell Ariana you know because
we know that Ariana found out from the
cell phone video I thought Mariana found
out
first
I thought Ariana found out Wednesday
night
after the show I guess no what night was
Tom's show I believe it was Wednesday
night um so they both just randomly
happened to find out the same way Ariana
found out and told everyone oh oh oh
you're right you're right okay sorry
that's definitely what happened okay I
needed the timeline in my head and
that's what I believe and then Sheena
found out and she was like oh my god
when she happened to have been with her
when she found out okay that tracks okay
that makes sense
um
this is just it's getting crazier and
crazier Tom Sandoval also released
another statement I guess he saw the
dissatisfaction from his crapola first
statement I can't read so many
statements you know you get one you get
one he apologized to Ariana primarily
and at his actions the way he went about
them were completely wrong duh there's
also so much coming out now about
production because they are filming
apparently Raquel and Tom filmed a scene
they kissed so like we're still together
um and then but it was a kiss but it was
like I think their relationship is
complicated right now then there was
another scene that apparently was filmed
and Tom Sandoval was really unhappy with
it
um and he wanted to reshoot they were he
was told no and now he's refusing to
show up for filming
there's no way he's gonna turn like if
he doesn't show up to filming
then he won't show up to the reunion
then he doesn't have a job anymore and
then it's all over for him he has to
show up yeah I will be so disappointed
if either one of them
doesn't show up to the reunion like that
is so
that's such like a [__] thing to do
yeah I think they will
I hope that they will
this Saga just keeps unfolding also Tom
Sandoval was seen going to therapy
okay that was obviously staged yeah like
he was seen going to therapy like what
like when they're following him
everywhere yeah in that he went to
therapy right because he knew people
were following him like I I mean there's
probably cameras and we have to watch a
scene with Tom Sandoval telling a
therapist right I don't know why I do
this leave me alone I have no ounce of
like Grace or even remote like sympathy
for Tom Sandoval like you know what I I
could make an argument about Raquel she
really is this like
very
like easily manipulated quiet shy like I
and there's no honestly there's no
excuse for that like you're 30. get it
together
um but like I could make an argument for
like how Raquel potentially I Have A
Little Bit of Sympathy of the way that
Raquel is being treated just because
it's more than a human being can handle
yes
um uh and Tom Sandoval is being treated
the same way I have no sympathy I have
not one ounce of anything to give to Tom
Sandoval I literally don't I don't and I
feel like he's loving it like I just
really feel that way
which is crazy to think crazy to think
but like I wonder it's so messed up
because it's like they have to show up
for the ring and it's in their contract
and they don't want to be but like they
could probably bargain for more money to
come back next season the two of them
unless
I I don't know if their contracts are at
a place where they renew every year got
it okay oh yeah if either because it's
like people are saying they should get
fired it's like I think they might get a
promotion yeah well that's just so weird
about reality TV like the worse you are
the more you're rewarded which is why
it's such a toxic environment and why it
ends up being really good
um and it's like your personal life so
you need to like intentionally blow up
your personal life in order to succeed
in your career but then like your
personal life and your career are
completely at odds a hundred percent if
either one of them are in a position
where their next contract where their
contract ends at the end of the season
then yes they are both going to be
flying high yeah which is just crazy to
think crazy to think
so what do you think do you think we're
gonna hear from Ariana like I was
thinking you know I could see like Alex
Cooper getting in there and like you
know getting Ariana on the chair but
because they have this show like that's
their platform like they're not gonna
give this moment to someone else already
Lala said she'd record an episode with
some cast members talking about it and
production
assisted it they had to record something
else it will be out later today but it
should have been out this morning but it
got delayed because production is like
probably not trying to ruin their own
show no good like they really should
keep everything and I know we're all so
eager to like know what's going on right
now
um but let's let's let it unfold like I
really do want to see how it plays out
on the TV show I don't really don't want
to hear podcasts you know what they
really should be doing but is getting
the love Island editors yep in the
studio and putting out episodes now we
care now we'll care again in a few
months and we'll everyone will be
watching but like
you're we're never going to care as much
as we do right now no and at the end of
the day this entire Saga is a real
um case study in how traditional reality
TV is Antiquated people's attentions are
spans are so short how you can like you
really are letting this moment go by not
capitalizing it capitalizing on it for
the show right now and they also need to
be editing the next episodes
condensing them yep so that there are
like episodes after and we don't have to
watch you know Sheena getting her nails
done talking about some nonsense so
there's fewer episodes that we have to
watch until the Big Break yeah
honestly I could argue that a big chunk
of this season could be cut like let's
just keep the Tom and Schwartz stuff I
mean the Schwartz and Raquel stuff just
to see like what the [__] their angle
was there and then to make you know the
bombshell of Raquel and Sandoval even
more
yeah big yeah
so that's the latest
oh my God totally random tangent right
now you want to hear something so
devastating
um
my local Dwayne Reed is going out of
business which is like if you live in
New York like your local Dwayne Reed is
life support but based on everything
you've shared with us or I don't even if
you said on the show like it makes sense
it's getting robbed like every day no
yeah okay so every time you walk in
there there's somebody holding up you
know the entire store with a knife but I
still need that like what I can't tell
you how many times in the middle of the
night like we've had to run out in the
Dwayne read like there's no read on
every I understand and I also don't
learn like I live in like a a
residential area so there's not a ton of
businesses yeah there's not like all
right okay I'll walk with another block
to the other Bodega there isn't and I
just I'm upset
I'm sorry Terry it's been really tough
my local pharmacy going out well there's
gopuff yeah and you'll have to just be
better about keeping stock of everything
yeah when my last apartment I wasn't
really I wasn't technically near to a
pharmacy but I didn't live on top of one
which means I wasn't yeah and you had to
get stuff on Amazon you just have to be
like more aware of it I know Vigilant
Vigilant you can't just like go down for
a snack a bag of chips no and can I tell
you how many times I've just gone down
for a Hershey bar like a little
something sweet yeah no I used to live
on top of Pharmacy three Apartments ago
and wasn't it I did my grocery shopping
there yeah of course my God Ben's always
coming back from the pharmacy with like
avocados I'm like where did you get that
yeah it's like Dwayne Wade no now you
gotta
instacart so it's just like something
difficult I'm dealing with on a personal
level that I wanted to share I'm really
sorry about that thanks thanks for your
support I hope something great comes in
into the space that's a great Point
that's a great point something that big
um
I know I'm surrounded by Banks
yeah you only need whatever one is yours
which there already is in your
neighborhood
I guess that's true put a positive spin
on it I really didn't think about what
might be coming next like a lunch spot
oh my God don't play with me a lunch
spot it's too big for a lunch spot what
a like a spot that sells warm bowls um
I love a warm bowl yeah
it's not a great location for a lunch
spot no you live like but there's a lot
of like fashion near you too yeah it
could be fashion
great what if it were Amazon fashion
oh my God if they open like an Amazon go
you know those like Amazon stores
perfect for you they have like a
Starbucks in there they also have a
bookstore yeah
and you don't have to pay like your
phone just like dings and you can walk
out with all your [__] I love that
that's what's what you need manifest it
charity Lou a man even though there is
an Amazon go like two blocks away so
they're not gonna open one maybe it does
so well they need another manifest I'm
manifesting
are you ready for our next story yeah
Cara Delevingne is on the cover of Vogue
talking about her substance abuse and
entering a 12-step program she says I
was not okay oh Cara Delevingne is
speaking out about getting help in an
interview for the April cover of Vogue
the model and actress shared that she
entered a 12-step program after
paparazzi photos last year gave her an
urgent wake-up call explaining that her
behavior was tied to the pandemic's
effect and her Milestone 30th birthday
last August so we all remember the
paparazzi photos
um she explained that she was like
coming from burning man the party just
never stopped and she thought she was
having a good time until she saw those
photos she said quote I hadn't slept I
was not okay it's heartbreaking because
I thought I was having fun but at some
point it was like okay I don't look well
you know sometimes you need a reality
check so in a way those pictures were
something to be grateful for but just as
she was celebrating her 30th birthday
alongside her Wide Circle of Friends
with an elaborate Alice in Wonderland
themed party her world was crumbling she
said quote I always kind kind of knew
that things were going to have to be
different in my 30s because the way that
I was living was not sustainable I
should have been having such a good time
I've got all my friends here I need to
be enjoying this
she said the house I was staying in had
a tower and I would just kind of lock
myself in it instead I barely left the
room there was this much there was this
need for change but I was fighting it so
much I was welcoming in this new time
but I was also grieving it was like a
funeral for my previous life a goodbye
to an Era and so I decided I was going
to party as hard as I could because this
was the end but the next month she said
she realized she needed help if she was
going to turn a new page on her life in
her career from September I just needed
support I needed to start reaching out
and my old friends I've known since I
was 13 they all came over and we started
crying they looked at me and said you
deserve a chance to have joy she soon
entered rehab where she found an
additional buttress thanks to a 12-step
program she said put this process
obviously has its ups and downs but I've
started realizing so much people want my
story to be this after school special
where I just say oh look I was an addict
and now I'm sober and that's it and it's
not as simple as that it doesn't happen
overnight of course I want things to be
instant I think this generation
especially we want things to happen
quickly but I've had to dig deeper
before I was always into the Quick Fix
of healing going to a week-long retreat
or to a course for trauma say and that
helps for a minute but it didn't really
ever regret to get to the nitty-gritty
deeper stuff this time I realized that
12-step treatment was the best thing and
it was a about not being ashamed of that
the community made a huge difference the
opposite of addiction is connection and
I really found that in 12 step
wow I feel like I never expected this
because I again it reminds me honestly
of Charles Kelly I think like Cara
Delevingne being like a big party girl
it hasn't even been like an Open Secret
it's just like a thing people knew
there's like paparazzi photos of her
accidentally dropping her keys and a bag
of coke flies out like there's like I
think there's pictures of her doing like
bumps on boats like it's just like
that's her she's the party girl
um
so for her to like really dive into the
12-step like I love this for her I'm I
think this is great yeah and I mean I
think that's what she's saying is like
she was a party girl she always knew
that her 30s would have to be different
because like that is not sustainable but
I think getting to the other side of it
was much more it wasn't just like oh
I'll I'll detox and go to retreat and
then I'll stop it's like I'm addicted to
this lifestyle and I need more help so
the 12-step program which has been
successful for so many people is where
she turned but I thought it was also
interesting where she said like it's not
like I was addicted and now I'm sober
like I think she's still going through
it and struggling with it but she's
obviously like made huge strides and I
think the hardest part is just the
accepting of the situation realizing
you're an addict and so she is it seems
very much on the road to recovery and
we've seen her a few times in the last
few months and she I mean she always
looks amazing yeah um on red carpets and
they always you know she like when she's
glammed and she's but then we saw her at
that award show no she's had like some
really kind of bizarre erratic behavior
in the last year so to hear that she's
been going through not only this like
struggle with addiction but also because
it's like kind of identity crisis about
like her 20s and her 30s actually makes
a lot of sense yeah it does and I'm glad
that she's sharing that because I think
it's something that a lot of people can
relate to and also it helps us just
understand her and she's someone who
like so many people follow and and I
feel like she's already connected to her
fans like she was like the biggest model
and the first is like supermodel really
on Instagram like yeah sharing so much
and so she's not just someone who like
we see from afar like I feel like then
her personality is so like everyone's
best friend yeah you know so I feel like
people will gain a lot from hearing her
story yeah I'm also just really happy
for her like I think you know that
lifestyle that like you know
socialite
cocaine party girl lifestyle like that's
a slippery slope so to and you're at 30
acknowledge that it's a problem and work
on it I think probably saved her life
yes definitely
I'm happy for her I really am and a
great cover and get for Vogue yeah and
she looked beautiful and so we're always
talking smack that yep we are always
talking smack about Vogue yeah and I
guess technically this could have been
like a British Vogue but American got it
wow you're totally right
a check in the column for American Vogue
the score is now two thousand to one
are you ready for our next story a
little Tick Tock news
little Tick Tock news it's brought to
you by thuma
let me be awesome introducing the bed by
thuma handcrafted from eco-friendly high
quality upcycled wood the bed by thuma
has a modern minimalist design that
helps Elevate any space so if you are
having a frustrating or disappointing
experience putting together furniture
for your bedroom look no further than
thuma their bed is put together by using
the Timeless technique of Japanese
joinery each piece locks into place
meaning no tools or excess Hardware are
required for assembly with clean lines
subtle curves and a lifestyle enhancing
detail bed the bed is simple
sophistication for the bedroom and their
perfect platform bed just got better
because you can now customize the bed by
choosing between the original pillow
board or the new solid wood headboard
the fabric pullerboard adds softness and
color to any space while the headboard
offers solid and Sleek support it's made
for how you live so the bed comes
with a lifetime warranty and it ships
right to your door in three easy to
maneuver boxes it takes about five
minutes to assemble with no tools
required the mattress um the nightstand
and the side table are also offered by
thuma and they're perfect complements to
the bed
they also have financing options
available on the thuma website create
that feeling of checking into your
favorite Hotel Boutique Suite but at
home with the bed by thuma and now go to
thuma.co toast to receive a 25 credit
towards your purchase of the bed plus
free shipping in the continental US go
to thuma.co toast that's
thumatuma.co toast for 25 credit thank
you Zuma for sponsoring today's episode
today's episode is also brought to you
by seed nurturing your gut microbiome is
important to support a resilient immune
system in the fall and winter months
immunity is the top of everyone's mind
but what often gets missed in the
oversaturation of anti-cold and
anti-flue messaging is the role that
your gut microbiome plays in systemic
health
so throughout your life your gut
microbiome and your immune system work
together carefully to coordinate your
body's responses to the world and the
world within us even before we're born
microbiomes help set the foundation of
our immune system teaching our body how
to distinguish between benign substances
and pathogenic antigens seeds ds01 daily
symbiotic is a plant-based Prebiotic and
probiotic with 24 strain that has been
clinically and scientifically studied
for its benefits so it's free from 14
classes of allergens that are defined in
the efsa and that includes sugar-free
vegan soy-free Sesame free gluten-free
peanut free glyphosate ampa free
dairy-free shellfish free corn free
there's no binders no preservatives and
65 65 compliant so why seeds daily dso1
symbiotic is supreme
um because it's specifically geared
towards digestive health and that makes
sense because people take probiotics for
Digestive Health so there's also skin
benefits it has four specific probiotic
strains that have been shown to promote
healthy skin and reinforce healthy
gut skin access
so avoid gut Mania and head to the
trusted sources for symbiotics start a
new healthy habit today and visit
seed.com toast and use code toast to
redeem 20 off your first month of seeds
ds01 daily symbiotics that's s-eed.com
toast and use code toast seed.com toast
code toast thank you Claudia yeah well
our next story Tick Tock is launching a
series feature which lets creators sell
premium episodes up to 20 minutes each
Tick Tock is opening up a new
monetization spigot for creators on the
popular short forearm video app the
Chinese owned app announced series a new
way for creators to sell their stories
as premium content with the series
feature available initially only to
select creators users can post
collections of Premium content behind a
paywall that viewers can purchase each
individual series can include up to 80
videos each up to 20 minutes long giving
the tick tock Community quote a new
longer format to watch their favorite
creators and content the company said
right now the maximum length of a tick
tock video is 10 minutes
and even that like nobody really uses
yeah um
I don't know how I feel about this
honestly I don't know if Tick Tock is a
platform for long form content I mean it
does sound like a great thing to use for
podcasts like long form I get it but I
just don't feel like that's what people
go to tick tock for agree people's
attention stands have been increasingly
shortened by Tick Tock so then to like
go back to long form it's like that's
like Netflix giving us binging and then
dropping things episodically like you
invented this we don't watch things for
20 minutes anymore and I don't think a
20 minute video is enough to titillate
like the average Tick Tock user's brain
like they're they it's it's all about
like the scroll like you watch chances
of a video like you don't even like it
you just scroll it's it's really not how
users have been
behaving thus far on this app yeah so
it's bizarre I like that I do what I do
like about Tick Tock is like they do put
creators first like top of mind for
creators it's like a lot of people is
there this is their full-time job so a
lot of people make money off the Creator
fund which is basically like YouTube ads
like you make money from just being a
big
Persona on there more so than Instagram
Tick Tock really puts the creators like
as a priority so that I like in just
creating another Revenue opportunity for
creators is is great but I don't see
this like really panning out yeah I'm
prepared to be wrong but I think this is
a flop of an idea yeah I feel like there
are some creators who might be able to
Parlay it into success like if I think
about like some of the cooking videos
where it's really really quick but it's
like hey I actually want to make that
like can we see a whole last 20 minute
video of the recipe good point I think
like some of those people might have
success but some people are just doing
dumb [__] [__] and I don't need I
mean I'm not a tick tock user so y'all
don't need to be seeing 20 minutes of
that you you liked and sometimes what
you like about a video is that it leaves
you wanting more so yeah I don't know if
people will go for this I don't know if
people will pay for this and like people
pay like if I'm paying for something I
want a premium viewing experience I want
to watch it on my TV I want it to be big
budget production like not some crapola
on my phone
yeah I just don't like when these big
apps like create habits for users and
then break those habits like it's
confusing
yeah I think I think it's usually
unsuccessful or it takes years
to job success and I don't know Tick
Tock has like days weeks Tick Tock the
clock is ticking Tick Tock the clock
don't stop
literally like your time might be up
soon so but it is crazy how like on
YouTube if you have viewers like you
have money yeah same with Tick Tock can
you if you are like a huge tick tocker
can you live off the Creator fund live I
mean it depends where you live in
um but the Creator Fund in terms of like
a CPM to YouTube is minimal but what's
crazy is like if you will have an
Instagram 20 million followers unless
brands are sponsoring you you don't make
money from the app right
and by the way
because Instagram copies whatever
everything everyone does they have
started to offer creators oh yeah they
have subscriptions now that and also
reels bonuses which is very similar to
like The Tick Tock Creator fund I'm like
getting you know 150 when you hit a
certain amount of views so it's on a
smaller scale and Tick Tock is is good
with that but in terms of actual money
offerings it's not nearly as good as
YouTube and a lot of people feel like
when they opt into the the tick tock
Creator fund to start making money their
views actually go down significance
yeah I joined the Creator fund when I
first started Tick Tock and I think you
have to have like 10 000 followers and I
would check like once every six months
and there would actually be 11 in there
and I had seen people saying that you
know their views were suppressed
significantly when they joined the
Creator fund so I opted out because I
wasn't even like I also okay keep your
twelve dollars yeah I Want My Views baby
I do I get paid more for a brand for my
views right views are a form of currency
too and I think they're more valuable
than what the tick tock Creator fund
offers creators
interesting very interesting
yeah YouTube is really and even YouTube
isn't like there compared to everyone
else like they look like they're
extremely generous but it's still
it's really not what creators should be
getting paid like it's no the big
YouTubers make like millions of dollars
from YouTube ads yeah but they have like
crazy engagement yeah but at least like
that's something it's a livable wage
yeah
no there are a lot of tick tock creators
who have millions of followers who are
in the Creator fund but haven't quit
their full-time jobs like it's really
supplemental income it's not it can't
really replace
just with the Creator fund unless you're
doing other things like starting a
podcast and doing brand deals and
writing a book and I don't know whatever
a Blog just the Creator fund is not uh
a replacement but just being a YouTuber
is yeah yeah I don't know what everyone
is launching subscription services like
everywhere you go Instagram like we said
now Tick Tock apple apple Spotify I like
patreon like uh well that's the patreon
and only fans cover the gamut of like
extra content and if you are a Creator
um while these these sound awesome wow
an apple subscription I can you know I
don't have to go to patreon or anything
that you um make money on through an app
in the app store Apple takes 30 of so
when you do an apple subscription for a
podcast or you do a Spotify for
subscription and you're paying for it
just know 30 of what you're paying for
does not go to the Creator which sucks
and that's why platforms like only fans
and patreon are so popular because
there's definitely like a small
percentage like a processing fee but
it's not even comparable to the 30 that
Apple takes Apple it is if you want to
be on the App Store you literally have
to that's Cameo too
that's why if you were buying a cameo
from someone do it on your computer
because though that if you send a
hundred dollars on Cameo on a computer
you get more so if someone signs up for
our patreon through the patreon app
oh that's a good call
I don't know if you can sign up on the
app
you definitely can I feel like you could
I mean
I don't know that's a good call
but like I remember when I did Cameo for
um
like February or I did it in June most
recently sometimes you would get uh
someone buying you a cameo and let's say
your fee is a hundred dollars and
sometimes you'll get 70 if they bought
it through uh apple and if they bought
it through a computer you get the
hundred well no Cameo takes a fee well
yeah but it's minimal compared to apple
yeah but it's like 15 or 20 no no no no
no no no no
it's not that much
well anyways I like having all my stuff
separate I go here for this I go there
for that and I don't know if that's like
sustainable and I feel like everyone's
trying to make like one large ecosystem
but mm-hmm I don't know I but my large
ecosystem is my phone the phone has
everything that's such a good one and
then I like to be organized within it
so right the ecosystem is the phone
right yeah it's like the ecosystem is my
Apple TV and then I want all my apps
depending on what my mood is no you're
so right
like why do we have to make it more
complicated like try so hard everyone
wants to be the one but it's like just
be grateful for where you are and what
you have
isn't it enough Tick Tock is it enough
Tick Tock you're not making enough money
you don't take up enough of people's
time so you know
are you ready for our next story yeah
another Creator Judy Bloom and her fans
explore the author's Legacy in the
trailer for a new documentary Judy Bloom
forever oh my God that's so sweet the
life and work of celebrated author Judy
Bloom is set to be documented documented
in the upcoming film Judy Bloom Forever
on Wednesday imagine documentaries in
Prime video exclusively shared the
trailer for Judy Bloom forever with
people the documentaries trailer shows
Bloom 85 and her impact on her fans as
the filmmakers explore the author's
Journey from fearful imaginative child
to storytelling Pioneer who elevated the
physical and emotional lives of kids and
teens to be to band writer who continues
to fight back against censorship today
it will be premiering at the Sundance
Film Festival
and just as a celebration of Judy Bloom
and the magic of an awkwardness of being
young straight back honestly I haven't
thought about Judy Bloom in years but
but to deny her impact on me as a young
woman would be disgraceful
um I love this can you remind me what
what books are you there God it's me
Margaret yes
um did she also have that series with
that like nutty little girl which one
there's so many the fruity nut cake you
know what I'm talking about super fudge
no
double fudge Tales of a Fourth Grade
Nothing but what's the one
I think the one is are you their God
it's me of course of course no but there
oh uh
no there's like all of these are
irrelevant Uglies
if also was it Ramona and Beezus
was it
blubber
blubber oh yeah these covers when you
look at the covers they really uh
they bring back some sometimes
Freckle Juice
oh man I'm so glad she's getting a
documentary she's so sweet she was
banned
is that what you would yeah that's what
she was a band I don't know maybe like
are you there God to me Margaret was a
little too provocative let me see Judy
Bloom band
and by the way it's important to know
Judy Bloom is a Jewish Queen We Live for
that
perfect
double fudge that was like one of her
more iconic books
yeah but there's like a book I'm
thinking about like a fruity nut cake
does anybody know what I'm talking about
there's another offer I think it's Lewis
um
Lewis say car
who also wrote like the books that we
read when we were this age and like I'm
just having a vivid memory but maybe it
wasn't Judy Bloom Lewis Thatcher books
oh he wrote holes
he wrote
um
what do you keep saying that you think
it is fruity nut cake like I'm having
this like really vivid memory about it's
not Roald Dahl
books for kids
and there's like this nutty sick figure
on the on the
look up Lewis Thatcher I feel like he
might be your guy no
and Louis Thatcher is the one where you
have to kiss your elbow right
I have literally no idea what you're
talking about you don't zero
oh maybe I'm thinking of Amelia Bedelia
Queen
if anybody knows what the [__] I'm
talking about like please drop a comment
oh my God yeah this book is called is he
a girl and it's if you can kiss your
elbow but you can't like try kissing the
tip of your elbow you can't it's so hard
but if you do it you can turn into a
girl well that book would not fly in
today's climate is he a girl no I mean
so many of these books are maybe that's
what they're talking about when Judy
Bloom was being banned yeah no I think
she was probably banned for being like
you know
exploratory well she did talk about not
sex but like vaginal Health in a sense
like it was very um anatomical I don't I
honestly don't remember she was a queen
I love her I'm glad she's getting a
documentary I hope she wins some sort of
uh Film Festival award and speaking of
the band books roll dolls books are
being like Rewritten
do you have you seen this yeah to be
more you know PC with the time like
Augustus Gloop isn't that anymore but
he's like but he is so you can change
them they changed it I think he's like
big as hell you can change the book but
you can't change facts
is Jermaine to the story oh and by the
way like everyone is are we erasing fat
people
the Erasure of Augustus Gloop is
disgusting it's disgusting and you know
what I won't [__] stand for it I'm
not into this you know what things were
different in the past can we just leave
it at that yeah no it's a rewrite and by
the way I like how there's no one
talking about a Roald Dahl is a bug of
raging anti-semite yeah but he was mean
to the people like okay our best
priorities are Augustus is still big as
hell in the book and his weight is
Germaine to the story yeah of course
because the reason he uh uh he's a
gluttonous yes
so like congratulations you did [__]
nothing congratulations you played
yourself
are you ready for our next story which
is one of our favorite subjects turdy
Lou yeah yeah
a Powerball winner who won two billion
dollar Powerball prize files for
bankruptcy nope is moving on up because
he just bought a huge mansion in
Hollywood for 25 million dollars his
neighbors will be Jimmy Kimmel and
Ariana Grande and the house is [__]
sickening honestly I would have done the
same thing with my earnings like yeah oh
I can't be a star I'll live with them
yeah he took his payment so it came to
997 million before that is before taxes
so he's got about half a half a bill
half a bill yeah I'm gonna assume I
wonder if lottery winners still uh get
mortgages I hope he's being financially
smart like he's has an advisor or
something because you should still get a
mortgage even if like there's no reason
you should put down 25 mil put down five
yeah yeah but also he's getting sued by
a man that claimed that his winning
lottery ticket was stolen believing that
Edwin is the name of the winner was
involved in the alleged theft
but the the power bill is standing
behind Edwin as the white rightful
winner
um and so does it say what else he's
bought or is this his first big purchase
this is the first one that we know oh is
this like the most recent
the recent winner the big Powerball but
we never got like for a while I feel
like he didn't claim because things were
quiet and we never even did a story on
like here's the winner his life is
changing but his name is Edwin Castro
where was he from like California
originally or now he just because he has
the money he wants to live in Hollywood
yeah that's a great question
who is Edwin Castro
he was California okay
so he's not uprooting his entire life
yeah like hopefully his family's there
and they can keep him grounded
I just I always worry about you know you
think two billion dollars like I'll you
know have money for Generations but not
only do you get like 25 of it
it's easy to run through money
yeah so people think that they found
he's a FIFA streamer they found his
username and this is a message that he
posted when he won it's unclear if this
is like really him but he shared a 10
second video of someone saying not to
message him because they won't get a
response quote I just want to say anyone
that's got my number please delete it I
have no time for you anymore
please don't message me because you
won't get a reply life's changed now yes
mic drop I'm out poor people if you knew
me before you don't know me anymore you
don't know the billionaire Edwin Castro
Money Changes people and Edwin Castro is
no different and he's not afraid to
admit it love and respect to him uh yeah
I think when you win two billion dollars
you have to change your phone number
first and foremost a hundred percent
like the people that come out of the
woodwork like hey my foot hurts can you
take me to the doctor yeah or just like
people who are like do I have this
person's phone number from middle school
like let me try all of a sudden billions
of texts no and you really there are so
many phone numbers out there actually
there's this guy on Tick Tock who goes
around and asks people who's the most
famous person they have in their
contacts like weirdly everyone has
someone's phone number who's like
celebrity adjacent because celebrities
were normal for a while and some of them
don't change their numbers and like some
of them you know you get drunk out at a
bar you give it out like people people
have phone numbers yeah or like someone
knows someone who knows someone who and
it's like everyone's like passing like
oh my God I have so-and-so's phone
number by the way like when I was in
high school I think Margo somebody got
Rachel Zoe's phone number oh and it was
real and like we would text her and call
her and like literally bother her and
like she eventually changed her number
but not you admitting to harassment yeah
I did that [__]
I was really young I have a vague memory
of one of my friends having Courtney
Cox's phone number
and she but I never tried or anything it
was just like enough to just have it
that's funny that's so me that's so you
like just call her call her up no what
have you just called Courtney up
I wonder if I still have it because I
nah I don't think I do because at one
point I used to like change over all my
contacts but there was one time where I
did it manually so that I only did the
need to knows it was still like 10 years
ago but now I don't have her hmm oh let
me check if I still have Rachel though
Rachel I do who's the most famous person
in your phone
probably Gwyneth
yep that'll do it that'll do it what
about you besides me
I don't know
I don't know because everyone's like an
influencer you know what about Iris yeah
I was actually just thinking Iris yeah
iris app fell it's probably a pretty
good one yeah that's pretty cool yeah
was that our fifth and final it was okay
great let's dive into Deer toasters our
weekly advice segment that uh we do
every Wednesday if you ever want to
write in the email account is
deertoesters gmail.com you could write
in about anything in order to get chosen
keep it interesting keep it brief keep
it funny keep it turdy you know
keep it charity deer toaster is brought
to you by the State Farm personal price
plan it helps you create plan that gives
you options so you get an affordable
price and it comes with a lot of
benefits too like the coverage you want
a policy that helps cover what's
important to you and an affordable price
just for you because after all life is
just better when you can personalize
your experiences personalizing certain
things in our life makes things so much
better like you know playlists what's
more personal than playlists comedy was
more personal than comedy poetry what's
my personal than poetry food
personalization means you have the power
to choose what you want you can choose
what you want to include you can choose
what you want to leave out it just feels
better that way and why shouldn't
insurance work like that too so true Jax
like we're so similar but even our
insurance plans are different you're
like a homeowning queen we have
different needs turdy Lou we have Auto
policies everyone thanks for the scene
but we're not look at our insurance look
at our insurance
that's what the State Farm personal
price plan is all about you can choose
to include options like bundling your
home and auto policies which means that
you'll get the coverage you want at an
affordable price just for you and in the
end you'll have a policy that gets
better and gives better no you'll have a
policy that gives you what you want
doesn't that feel better yeah like a
good neighbor State Farm is there like a
good neighbor
say Farm is there
call or go to statefarm.com today to
create your State Farm personal price
plan prices vary by state options
selected by customer availability and
availability and eligibility may vary
all right ready ready
dear Jackson Claude I'm a 20 21 year old
college student who was in a moral
dilemma growing up I always had this
favorite band their concert
um I went to recently was near my
University when I went to the concert I
had the opportunity to meet them one of
the members talked to me a lot and we
kind of hit it off and he asked to
follow me on Instagram and then
proceeded to DM me saying it was nice to
meet me the next morning I looked at his
Instagram and to my surprise I saw on
his profile that he was married with
three kids around a year later he dm'd
me and told me he was going to be
playing a concert near my school again
oh my God he was messaging me and
practically practically begging me to
come backstage before the concert I went
to the concert and I talked to him it
was nice and chatty but nothing I
wouldn't have said if his wife was there
after the concert I told him that my
friends and I were at the concert and
that we were headed home he responded
with if I came back with you what's in
it for me I'm sure he's doing this with
other girls he meets on touring but do I
DM the wife and let her know that her
husband is actively trying to hook up
with girls 10 years younger than him and
I'm sure uh with others he is actually
successful does she need to know or
would I be causing drama where there
doesn't need to be sincerely girl who
needs to find a new favorite band girl
dropped the name I'm curious oh my God
like I thought maybe at the bottom like
she would tell us who it is no I have to
say the way she describes it it sounds
like it's a band like we wouldn't maybe
not know like it's like a small Time
band you know really yeah that's just a
vibe that I got no I got like New Kids
on the Block like oh I got like Big Time
Rush
time right like we're kind of not far
off from each other no like you know on
of some sort of like reunion tour like
had their heyday
yeah uh
I don't know this seems like a situation
where it's like mind your business
she'll find it yeah because also it's
like if he is Hollywood then like they
might have some sort of thing going and
I don't know I mean if it were me I
would absolutely want to know but
I don't know I I literally I honestly do
not know I know it's like women we like
owe each other stuff but like this is
not like a person you know it's not like
a friend I don't really feel honestly
she probably wouldn't even see the
message and I would say there's probably
a chance that she knows he's [__]
around on the road I think most
spouses of touring artists know that so
I don't feel like you would it would be
this big bombshell revelation I just
feel like mind your business
yeah I think I would just stay out of it
I don't want to be in the middle of this
and there's probably
stuff she does know
just and my dad suggests five seconds of
summer for a new band I love them could
have been five sauce
none of them are married with three kids
yeah that's true they're all young so
it's pretty harmless it could be like
Backstreet Boys yeah I mean if we wanted
to we could figure this out drop a
comment who do you think it is
how how can we figure it out we
literally couldn't there's so many old
bands touring no like band members who
have three kids and wives that are still
together honestly I don't feel like it's
that many Kevin Jonas has two kids right
yeah oh thank God
crisis averted
she [__] I can't believe that even came
to the top of your mind Kevin Jonas
[__] never [__] no because I was
just thinking about the Jonas Brothers
them being a band that came back that
you would like when you were younger
right the other two like I have one and
two babies for sure like I just needed
to confirm yeah no I think we can narrow
it down to the kids are probably young
like if you're looking at the person's
Instagram and they have pictures with
their kids like grown ass kids don't
take like a lot of photos with their
parents you know what I mean yeah I
don't know I don't know if you could say
that
and also what are we considering a band
like is this a Duo would we consider a
band because I had someone top of mind
even though they don't fit the profile
no
I'm thinking like Backstreet Boys New
Kids on the Block Big Time Rush I guess
oh wait she said growing up I always had
this band as my favorite yeah you're
right growing up
if she's a toaster I'm gonna say she's
about 30. it's Backstreet Boys
or nuke is on the Block
um
I don't know
I don't I don't see that whoever wrote
this in you absolutely have to let us
know we will not sure we won't share I'm
just curious now because you're nosy
like let us know but I I also want to
know if like we're getting warmer
right are we on track at all question
mark how many kids does Nick Carter have
that's an amazing question
you guys um
the rest of the episode is going to be
dedicated to figuring this figuring this
I think everybody's with us
three
is he married
for sure
yep
and by the way what we've learned about
Nick Carter in recent months is that
he's absolutely disgusting let's not
forget he is uh
being accused of rape correct yeah
raping a disabled fan right so unless we
not forget stay away from him yeah and
his wife knows right so you there's
nothing you tell her oh he dm'd based on
the [__] she probably already knows it's
mild and don't forget what Aaron accused
him of right
all right next up let me get to the
bottom of that and we can provide the
answer which is you don't need to say
anything because she knows yeah she
knows and now we knows hey Jackson turd
I'm a relatively new toaster and your
show is the only thing getting me
through my job I recently started as a
lawyer at a big law firm and I cannot
function I'm on call basically 24 7 and
I can never go a few minutes without
looking at my phone it's taking over
every aspect of my life and now I live
in constant states of anxiety even worse
I was told by people on my team that I
should not make any plans during the
week since I've expected to always be
around however everyone on my team is
married and I'm the only single one so
they don't understand that I need to
date during the week I can't just go out
on weekends the only way for me to do
this is to check my phone every 20
minutes or so on a date so I can
communicate with work is this okay to do
on a date I know on dates especially at
the beginning that I find it rude when
guys check their phones so it's so
hypocritical if I do it how do I go
about doing this PS I tell myself every
day that I'm quitting to get me through
so any suggestions that um are welcome
that involve me keeping my job thank you
okay I just want to say getting a job at
a big like one of those big law law
firms is a huge accomplishment so
congratulations to you and they pay
really well so yeah they pay really well
and like you have a track for your
career and if you like you know keep
working hard like big things will come
your way so I don't think that you
should quit and like you went to law
school like what what are you gonna do
like you're doing what you should be
doing but like if I were dating and I
went on a date with like a big lawyer
and he was really like successful and
like he really was doing the things he
said he was doing and like at the
beginning of the date he was like to me
like I'm so excited to be here I just
have to check my phone like every 20
minutes because of work stuff because
I'm like such a big deal
um I just I don't want you to think it's
rude I think that you could try that
like I think I would be understanding
like if I like this guy I could give him
a pass to check his phone every 20
minutes especially if like he's gonna be
a big success and then you get to check
your phone every 20 minutes which is
awesome for you too yeah I think being
like totally transparent about it in the
beginning is fine I also think I would
um is there like a woman on your team
who's married who you could just like
ask like if you're friendly with me like
girly like how do you live like this
like you're married how did you meet
your husband like also it would also be
beneficial for you perhaps to date
another lawyer so you know they
understand the hustle and the muscle so
if there's any cuties in your office
check it out yeah
um but then it's like her office you
know this reminds me of a book that I
read called the boys club by Erica Katz
it's literally about a girl who's like
working in big law and she you know kind
of spirals
and it might actually be too close to
home for you to read but I enjoyed it so
um maybe you should read it but it
doesn't sound like people have time but
I also really like the idea of you like
asking uh super not a superior but like
somebody who's married who obviously was
on the same track as you and just being
like hey question mark if everyone else
is married it's clearly a possibility
yeah like how did you meet your husband
like how did you I'm like really
struggling today like because I don't
want to drop the ball on work stuff so
you have any advice for me sister yeah
great question and to find a way to like
understand like what needs to be
addressed like some things are not need
to do this minute exactly so I don't
know how long you've been there but
maybe just after a certain amount of
time you'll be better at like a lot of
people you know they move the mouse on
their computer and they're still working
you know yeah so something like that but
I would start with transparency and be
like listen I'm a big shot find a better
way to say it uh and I just need to
check my phone every 20 minutes I hope
that you're not offending so I'm really
excited to be here but like yeah I I
take a lot of pride in my job and I'm a
really big deal and I work really hard I
think people really respect
um honesty if I were on a date with
someone
and they said that I would have no
problem with it
me neither if they just right off the
bat said I'm not like you know bored I
just like absolutely have to check my
phone every 20 minutes so I don't lose
my goddamn job and be like Oh jobs am I
right and then that's a great thought
starting question but that would
actually like annoy me like a little bit
because it's like is he counting down
like to the 20th minute to check it out
then you're overthinking is he listening
to what I'm saying even you're
overthinking it
yeah give it a shot or find like someone
else with a really demanding job but
then like how would you guys ever meet
because you both have like two free
minutes a week
lunch
a working lunch yeah
let us know how it goes
third and final dear charity Lou and Jax
a hearing you say it's so rude to have
no regard for your partner's sleep has
really opened my eyes to my own
relationship and I need your help I
sleep over at my boyfriend's Place
frequently during the week because he
refuses to park his truck on the street
at my place so I go to him he has to
wake up for work hours before I do and
for a while now when he wakes up he
turns on all the lights in the apartment
and makes me leave when he does
to give you context he's got a one
bedroom apartment and he not only turns
on the bathroom light and living room
light both with the doors open to the
bedroom but he also turns on his bedroom
light while I'm still sleeping and makes
me leave before 7am when I don't really
need to be up before nine after hearing
you speak on this I told my boyfriend
that I would really like it if he did
not turn on the bedroom light while I'm
sleeping because it just dawned on me
how selfish that behavior is he then
told me I was rude for asking that of
him and that he quote pays for his
places in the lighting bill so he can do
whatever he wants with them for more
contacts we've been dating for a year
he's 30 and this just all seems like
childish and selfish behavior from
someone I thought I'd be engaged to this
year what would you do a confused
toaster I mean it's hard to like you
know I obviously need more contacts but
your boyfriend sounds like a prick yeah
you know it's like is it your house if
no if he's being a prick about the
lights like he's probably a prick
elsewhere I think you should just start
to be like listen I'm really tired
um I'm not sleeping I don't want to get
up at 7am when I don't have to I'm gonna
sleep at my place and just like put your
foot down and see if he comes to you a
little bit or can meet in the middle and
like you should be if he's your
boyfriend of a hearing should be able to
stay in his place and not have to leave
when he leaves that's [__] weird
that's like he doesn't trust you yeah
and like the sheer fact that he won't
make the effort to go to your apartment
because he has to park on the street
take an Uber ride a bike walk like but
it does sometimes make sense there's
always one person's apartment where it
makes more sense to stay for sure but to
refuse to go to your girlfriend's
apartment because you don't want to park
like he obviously sounds like he
literally sounds like a lazy oaf no he
sounds not like lazy of like a dictator
yeah no he sounds like a prick honestly
like and I would be curious if this sort
of energy and behavior like funnels its
way into other aspects of your
relationship I'd be shocked if it didn't
for sure there's no reason he needs to
turn on the bedroom lights there's no
reason why you have to get up at seven
kicking you out is the is the most
shocking part of this whole yeah that's
like what you do with a booty call right
it's so rude like throw them cab fare
and get out yes Graham there's no and
the fact that he doesn't let you be in
his apartment when he's not there is
also cause for concern
yeah I pay the lighting bills at my
place so I'm just gonna pay them here
and you're just gonna enjoy I'm just
gonna enjoy my lights yeah it sounds
like torture
yeah and see if he comes to you and if
not then you realize like you're the one
who's been literally putting in all the
effort to everything yeah
let us know how that goes
that's our show Jax it is
thank you so much
I hope you have a safe flight I hope you
have a wonderful time with your popular
friends thanks I'll be sure to fill you
in on all the details about the popular
girl said about you
please don't thank you guys so much for
listening to the toast the millennial
Morning Show where we deliver the past
five stories that you need to know every
Monday through Friday on YouTube so
you're watching us on YouTube please
subscribe give this video a thumbs up
we're also available as podcast indoor
podcasts we found so on Spotify
we love you and we will see you back in
studio on Monday back in studio on
Monday but we'll see you tomorrow on the
patreon episode we'll be up early in the
morning probably earlier than the toast
is usually up if you're looking for
content and
perhaps Friday as well turdy and I are
working on it yup gotta coordinate love
you bye